at least 150 at least 150 which is not
exactly number but it's a range its
range it's it's a number of how many
former Apple people work at Tesla now
and that's important because Tesla's are
employing more former Apple workers than
from any other company that it has right
now that's Ben Lewin saying how the cars
are being designed how they the user
experience and even how they're sold
yeah I mean I'm constantly critical
Tesla's financials but the car is is a
design wonder it comes at a time when
traditional automakers are struggling to
hire people in Silicon Valley it it's
just another challenge they face against
this new upstart company I also wonder
how much the the the deal were Apple
wasn't letting anybody know the sort of
global case with a lot of tech companies
weren't allowed to pochi who decided to
collude and not let people poach
employees from one company to the next
well yeah and musk is now telling us
that he feels that Apple's trying to
take his employees back really um and
are easy much of the other carmakers why
not the other carmakers having the same
kind of success well this gets back to
tradition of the auto industry I mean
who wants to live in Detroit you got to
you lived in Detroit I mean I think it's
a great place for Michigan it's a lovely
place
solutely put it in Silicon Valley it's
also true I